but do you want me saying so more
importantly how do you want me says I
could stand here and rate my world to
you
like it's the opening credits of a
disaster movie this is the set up 2050
far enough in the future for all this to
seem plausible climate catastrophe
reported as normality the daily index of
maximum time allowed outside in Doha or
Austin or Manchester in all these places
it is over 50 degrees centigrade if you
go outside for more than your allotted
hour then you will die some specific new
tragedy targeted by weapon takes out
Cape Town as the staple it's of a
collapse South Africa fight for water
first use of live ammunition
to keep the hordes out on the Italian
Swiss border I could be a newsreader if
we still have those a citizen
journalists screaming into a phone
against the backdrop of burning
old-growth forests ported into your
optic nerve through a neural network a
studio improvised in a spare bedroom -
half a billion subscribers but not
anything we'd recognize as TV news or
newspapers obviously whatever a
newspaper looks like then we're probably
imagining it wrong
whatever happens whatever lies look like
and whatever truth becomes
it probably won't look like this
this isn't really the future this is an
idea of the future that by the time
you're watching it is in the past anyway
this is what the future looked like in
our heads in 2019
I'm just here saying how do you want me
to talk to us should we talk about
dystopia
maybe but dystopia is weird isn't it it
feels now like we might have made a
mistake about it depending on which
version of this future world I'm in
right now of course I mean maybe we
scared ourselves a bit too much
all that footage of rising oceans and
rioting in the cities and the streets of
London underwater and one filthy polar
bear that was all ribs and hunger and
sadness all those water wars
desiccated dead piled in the
uninhabitable streets and the rise of
idiots feeding all fear with simplistic
solutions
don't get me wrong a lot of that
happened or from where you're watching
this a lot of that is going to happen
the processes are in motion dengue fever
gearing up for a welter extreme heats
eyeing up more people than just the old
or young or sick people are dying of
this stuff right now but if that's what
we tell ourselves we internalize the end
the idea of it we lie down in the face
of it because it's just too big and then
that is the end because we'll put our
trust need to be saved from all that in
things we can't see yes we'll take the
chance of an off moment of inspiration
over the provable reality that's just
the way we're built the big discoveries
are self-regenerating bodies and fusion
power and everything choirs and humming
and electric bringing the global
temperature down with sulfates or
electric cars or some method of clean
energy we haven't even thought of yet
our ability to pull salvation out of the
apocalypse hat at the last minute to
carbon capture our way out of this the
idea there's a soul solution that'll
save us through the power of Eureka is
seductive
and we're trying all these things we are
but whatever arrives if it does it can't
reach back through time to now we never
really worked out how to talk about this
we probably should have I mean it's not
as if we didn't know even if some of us
took comfort in the voices that only
told us what we wanted to hear and then
we spent a long time trying to blind
ourselves with science and we're sorry
that didn't necessarily work graphs
graphs red lines colors and
concentrations parts per million and
rises of degrees and millimeters and we
look around ourselves and think don't we
these numbers are too small or too large
gone meaningless
what does two degrees mean on a cold day
and what does it mean decades from now
which of them is easier to feel in our
bones and then get on with our lives
if we could have some scientific facts
like pop songs we'd have got to the
chorus sooner but we didn't
it's not that we could have stopped
these things from happening but we'd
have been better prepared to face them
in a way that didn't kill so many of us
maybe we screwed ourselves up with too
much speculative fiction I could be
standing at the edge of the sea telling
you the future looks like this that most
of the streets you grew up in are behind
me in the waves this the countries that
have gone and the parts of countries
because they're underwater or you just
can't go outside in them where the local
biosphere is collapsed show you the
normal life that plays out against that
backdrop kind of warmer more beige
version of now with potholes and
soldiers on the streets everywhere
rather than just the poor places and
only three types of teeth list thing is
when you make the argument about
lifestyle degrading you either don't
want to believe it because you think
you're immune or you don't care because
you're already living it
but the one thing nobody told us was
that everything was going to be alright
nobody's serious anyway
and if that's what you heard it wasn't
what we were saying we never found the
way to make ourselves do enough fast
enough
coming some of us yes
but doing enough consistently talking in
a way that made this possible to grasp
in the quiet parts of life in the times
between the times that we all march know
we needed to make this as everyday as
bath time as graspable as pre-packed
sandwiches or your loved ones hand and
we didn't
every time we try to make the defining
statement we thought maybe this is the
one maybe this is the one that gets
through we didn't need data or heroes we
didn't even need voices pretending to be
from the future we're in the same place
it's not about our children or our
grandchildren anymore futures come to
meet us most of the people watching this
will be there when it happens
we needed to understand quietly every
day but this is the future now every
single second we're not waiting for the
future we're not trying to fend it off
we're living in it
it is now
and it is us
you